ocupada la espiral de violencia no Da
señales de terminar fue aquí en
Jerusalén este la parte de la ciudad
Santa ocupada por Israel desde 1967
donde un adolescente palestino disparó e
hirió a dos personas este sábado
por lo que entendemos se trata de una
emboscada de un terrorista de 13 años
esperó para emboscar a civiles que se
encontraban en la zona el ataque se
produjo contra cinco personas que hacían
sus oraciones tenemos dos civiles en
estado crítico un padre y un hijo el
agresor por su parte está bajo custodia
policial luego de que dos civiles
lograran herirlo tras el ataque
en estos momentos el terrorista se
encuentra en el hospital donde fue
enviado por las fuerzas y lo que sabemos
es que se trata de un aumento
significativo en el nivel del terror el
atentado se produce en el contexto de
una repentina escalada del conflicto
palestino israelí el viernes un
palestino de 21 años residente en
Jerusalén este disparó y mató a siete
fieles de una sinagoga antes de ser
abatido por la policía ataques que se
cree son en represalia luego de que el
ejército israelí llevara a cabo su
incursión más Sangrienta en sus Jordania
en dos décadas asesinando el 26 de enero
a nueve palestinos en el campo de
refugiados de jenning estos dramáticos
acontecimientos obligaron a cambiar la
agenda de la visita oficial del
secretario de estado Anthony blinquen a
Israel y a los territorios palestinos se
espera que el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense dialogue a puertas
cerrada con el gobierno israelí de
extrema derecha cuyas políticas
preocupan a la Casa Blanca